[Music]  he won last year's spirit award for best  male lead for his performance in  uncut gems adam sandler hello  i'm adam sandler the face of the  independent spirit awards  thank you so much if you're wondering  why i have an extremely hip beard now  it wasn't intentional last year after i  won  best male lead for my incomparable uncut  gems performance  this beard just appeared on my face  was it magic or was it the independent  spirits  that did it yes my wife and kids haven't  looked at me without cringing in over 12  months  but laz von trier gave me a bag of cbd  coffee for my birthday  and boney fair does transcendental yoga  with me  every morning so it's all good  independently speaking of course  you